So, those are examples of precondition.
There's another one.
Think for a second and
see if you can come up with one
other potential precondition.
>> So, for the last requirement, you
could be in a situation where someone
continually is trying to check out the
same vulnerable item over and over again
and one of our requirements states
that you can renew an item once once.
But, if there is another
outstanding request for
that item, then you shouldn't be allowed
to check it out because other people may
be wanting to check out the same thing.
>> We're talking about
checking out an item.
And if you've all ready got it checked
out and you want to keep it longer,
that's a renewal, not a check out.
>> But clearly, we're going to
have to deal with that situation
when we get to considering renewals.
>> So, the other possibility is
you'd like to check this out, but
it turns out that it's
the hottest bestseller,
and there's 44 people before
you in the list of requests.
>> So
even though you happened to find it,
because it was just put back,
it was put back by mistake and
they're not going to let check it out
because somebody else has requested it.
>> So, the request queue needs to be
empty so to speak for you to be able to.
>> Well, almost.
How about if you're
the person that requested it?
>> If you're the first
person that requested,
then the precondition should hold and-
>> Right.
>> Execute.
>> It's not am empty queue.
It could be a queue with one
thing in it or a queue actually
with any number of things in it as
long as you're top on the list.
>> Okay.